on l'a appris tard hier soir une page
d'histoire s'est tournée avec l' annonce
de la disparition de michael gorbatchev
le dernier dirigeant de l'urss s'est
éteint à l'âge de 91 ans des suites
d'une longue maladie il est l'homme à la
tâche devant sur le crâne et au sourire
nombreux qui tranche avec l'austérité de
ses prédécesseurs mihai gorbatchev au
pouvoir en urss de 1985 à 1991 l'homme
qui a voulu réformer lempire soviétique
et qui a finalement amené à sa
disparition dans la main de mireille le
gorbatchev l'acte de décès de l'urss ce
25 décembre 1991 il signe sa démission
l'ère soviétique se refaire
parvenu à la tête du parti communiste en
1985 il s'engage sur la voie des
réformes père de la pérestroïka la
restructuration et de la glace noces de
la transparence il a voulu moderniser
l'urss l'union de quinze républiques et
instaurer plus de démocratie dans ce
régime communiste mais pour la plupart
des russes il reste celui qui a trahi en
se rapprochant de l'occident des états
unis notamment avec lui la guerre froide
se termine et l'empiré soviétique
s'effondre
[Musique]
maintenant
m
[Musique]
guy bedos qui avait dit en son temps
gorgue de gorbatchev celui qui avait la
carte de l'afghanistan
dessiner sur la tête
un mot de guy bedos c'était le seul
humoriste de tous les temps avoir rempli
sa de france
il ya booba qui va remplir le stade de
france hier à nous
c'est fou
saastal dit adieu rempli quoi toi on
sait
oh la belle villa
à quelle fréquence
les hommes
se font-ils un petit plaisir qu'aucun
tout seul
au québec on mesure en verre
si une verge mesure 3 pieds à combien de
verges équivalent 12 pieds
[Musique]
ça
irait quatre essais une bonne
adresse en 54 fois par an exactement
voilà ça y va ça y va ça va la
brise les doigts pocas oh ça me brise
les noix 28 à 19 h tél belle expression
elodie est aux premières loges
les passes il serre les fesses serrées
fait spolier voilà
quatre problème c'est que le savent pas
si elles vont derrière ou devant tu vois
là ça va amplifier
leur
élan le sapin
la nouvelle fait la une de la presse
people
leonardo dicaprio est séparé de sa
compagne l'actrice et mannequin
argentine camilla morrone avec la fin de
cette histoire d'amour débutée il ya
quatre ans ressurgit ce graphique bien
connu d'internet et intitulé leonardo
dicaprio refuse de sortir avec une femme
de plus de 25 ans alors vous savez il ya
des gens dans la vie il rêverait d'être
réincarné en vaches et puis on a
d'autres qui rêveraient d'être réincarné
en recherches à l'origine à dori être
une chaise que je trouve que les chèvres
ses malicieux c'est fantasque c'est
j'adore les chèvres et vous attendez
vous
[Rires]
j'ai vraiment envie de faire la fête
j'ai vraiment envie de m'éclater chou
pas du tout au sérieux et en plus ça
j'ai fait moi je suis très fière
un internaute y a compilé les conquêtes
de l'acteur aujourd'hui âgé de 47 ans
ses petites amies elles sont toujours
jeune et aucune n'a dépassé le quart de
siècle à ses côtés c'est imparable et
camilla ne déroge pas à la règle elle a
eu 25 ans au mois de juin